I was in Berlin and I was alone in my
hotel and I remember there was like a
window right there and I like god I
remember crying because I was thinking
about how the way that I was gonna die
was I was gonna do it
Billy Eilish is getting really candid
about her struggles with depression
revealing she almost took her own life
while on tour in Berlin I was so unhappy
last year I was so unhappy and I was so
like joyless Billy opens up during Gayle
Kings Grammy special and I just want to
say I appreciate how honest and how
candid she's being and also a quick
reminder that if you're feeling this way
there is help out there I don't want to
be too dark but I genuinely didn't think
I would like we get to like 17 you
didn't think you'd make it to 17 no but
did you think that you would do
something to yourself yeah you did
mm-hmm
Billy says the lyric and Barry a friend
is about herself there's a lyric in one
of your songs where you talk about the
end of me I want to end me when I heard
that I thought god I wonder Billy was
talking about herself mm-hmm I was it
also rhymed
we're of course thankful Billy sought
help and changed her mind she says a lot
of that is because of her mom so why do
you think you didn't um laugh at my mom
yeah
your mom Billy Eilish is surrounded by
her mom and her dad and her brother you
know they all of these guys have a great
foundation and great support yeah and
Billy's mom made sure to help manage her
grueling schedule as she shot to
superstardom are you ready for the next
level of superstardom no I think I am
honestly you know I think I I feel like
your destiny now Billy says she hopes to
use her own experiences to help her fans
I just grabbed them by the shoulders and
I'm like please take care of yourself
and be good to yourself and be nice to
yourself don't take that extra step and
hurt yourself further then you can't and
you can't take it back and the singer
has a lot to look forward to she is
nominated for six Grammys on Sunday the
nomination is like the part that's
important because like it doesn't really
matter who wins it because it's like to
be even nominated at all to be in the
realm of the Grammys in any sort of way
is
indescribable other things that Billy
talks about in this Grammy special her
Tourette's syndrome nobody really knows
but it's like if you spend all day with
me and you sleep in the same bed with me
it's really intense it's like people I'm
like doing that the entire night and her
fashion I get the impression you don't
want us to see your body is that true
yeah me and my body's relationship has
been the most toxic relationship you
could even imagine the weird that people
are so intrigued and interested it's
it's really sick it's kind of exactly
what I would want people to care about
you know like I don't know the things
that people sort of know me for are all
the things I want to be known for if
that makes sense a style has always been
something I care about aside from all of
her nominations Billy will also perform
at Sunday's Grammy Awards on CBS until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now
[Music]